[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من العربيه احييكم ما انا ريما مكتبي وهذه
نشره الخامسه نبداها بابرز العناوين
[تصفيق]
منظمهن اجنبيه تعلن تعليق عملياتها في
افغانستان بعد قرار طالبان حضر التشغيل
النساء
عن الطعام واضرابات بمدينه بركان الكرديه
مستعد لتفاوض بشان حلول مقبوله للجميع
بشان اوكرانيا وكيف تتهم موسكو بتنصلي من
مسؤولياتها
الجيش الليبي يحضوا القوى السياسيه على
توافق على خطه للانتخابات ويحذر من
سيناريوهات سيئه
ونبدا نشره الخامسه من تداعيات قراري
طالبان حضر عمل النساء في منظمات غير
حكوميه فقد اعلنت ثلاث منظمات اغاثيه
اجنبيه
بمواصله قيام الرجال والنساء وبشكل متساوي
في تقديم المساعدات التي تنقذ الارواح
قرارات طالبان الاخيره والتي استهدفت او
استهدف استهدفت فيها المراه بمنعها من
التعليم الجامعي وعدم السماح بعملها في
المنظمات غير الحكوميه قبلت بادانه دوليه
وصفت بالقويه كما اشعلت احتجاجات واثاره
انتقادات شديده داخل الافغانستان
وانعكاسات القرارات سلبا على 28 مليون
افغاني تقول وكالات المنزه
انهم سيحتاجون الى مساعدات اغاثيه خلال
العام المقبل
واوضح نائب الممثل الخاص الى الامم
المتحده في افغانستان رامز الاكبروف
اوضح ان النساء اساسيات في العمليات
الانسانيه في جميع انحاء العالم وقد يكون
هذا القرار مدمرا بالنسبه للشعب الافغاني
وبالفعل علقت المنظمه الدوليه عملياتها
الاغاثيه منبهه الى ان منظمات غير حكوميه
اخرى في افغانستان تتخذ اجراءات مماثله
ومن كابل معنا مراسل العربيه عبد الله
نادر اهلا بك
طيب واوقفت ثلاث عمليات اغاثيه العمل هل
فعلا ستتاثر طالبان هل هذا يؤثر اي شيء
بحياه هذه الحركه او يمنعها من قراراتها
بحق النساء
لقرار الطالبان وكذلك الضحيه لقرار هذه
المؤسسات الدوليه والخيريه سواء كانت
دوليه او محليه هو الشعب الافغاني فالشعب
الافغاني هو المتضرر والشعب الافغاني هو
سيتاثر واذا ما قرر المجتمع الدولي وخاصه
المؤسسات الدوليه المانحه همم اغلاق همم
هذه المؤسسات فان الاقتصاد المحطم والهش
في افغانستان سيتضرر اكثر لان هذه
المؤسسات الدوليه همم كانت تقوم بدعم
الحكومه الافغانيه الحاليه وكذلك الشعب
الافغاني في قطاعات مختلفه بما فيها
القطاع التعليمي وكذلك القطاع الصحي
والقطاع تن- تنموي والمعماري وهذه
المؤسسات كان كانت تقوم بالدور فعال وبارز
همم في التنميه البشريه في افغانستان
وخاصه في القطاع الصحي اذا اقتصاده
افغانستان سواء كان الحكومي او الشعبي ااه
ضعيف همم طحنته همم الحروب المستمره في
هذه الاربعين همم السنه الماضيه وبالتالي
يرى المتابعون لشان الافغاني ان هذه
القرار الطالبان
سيؤثر بالشعب الافغاني وكذلك قرار هذه
المؤسسات بايقاف همم نشاطاتها وفعالياتها
الخيريه كذلك ضحيه هذا القرار كذلك الشعب
الافغاني
يعني موضوع قلب الراي العام او محاوله
المجتمع الدولي وقف مساعداته الانسانيه
يقلد الراي العام على طالبان ما هو
الاجراء الذي ممكن ان تتخذه المؤسسات
الدوليه او دول المجتمع الدولي همم ثاني
طالبان عن هذا القرار
هنا منظمه اكبر وهذه المنظمه تعتبر مظله
للمؤسسات الخيريه الدوليه وكذلك للمؤسسات
المحليه تعتبر منظمه سقف هذه المنظمه من
الان بدا جلساته واجتماعاته الاستشاري
لتباحث البديل همم اذا ما استمر طالبان في
تنفيذي هذا القرار
بايقاف وبالتعليقه باغلاق المؤسسات وبواب
المؤسسات والمنظمات امام السيدات
الافغانيات همم لحد الان ليست هناك اختيار
او بديل اخر همم مع هذه المؤسسات
والمنظمات الدوليه والمحليه الا انها ان
تدرس كيف تستطيع هذه تستطيع هذه المؤسسات
همم يعني همم فعالياتها وهمم
انشطتها وا الخيريه في في الداخل الافغاني
لحد الان هذه المؤسسات لم تعلن اي اي بديل
همم
لهذا القرار
كيف يواجه الافغان هذا القرار يعني تخذ
القرار من ايام ماذا حصل في الشارع
هناك احتجاجات في سوشيال ميديا وهناك
حملات ضد هذا القرار وخاصه النساء
والسيدات اللواتي كنا عملنا في هذه
المنظمات الدوليه والمحليه همم قلنا في
هذه الحملات بانهن لا يستطيعن العيش بدون
بدون الدخل بدون العمل في هذه المنظمات
الدوليه والمحليه التي تم حرمانهن من
العمل فيها ونحن قرانا تقارير يعني تحدثت
همم عن همم ردود فعل النهائي السيدات
اللواتي كنا يعمل له يعملنا حاليا في هذه
المؤسسات همم والمنظمات قلنا ليس لهن دخل
سوا هذا العمل وبالتالي المتضررات وهن همم
وهن هي هن هن السيدات اللواتي عملنا في
هذه المؤسسات وهؤلاء السيدات يقومن الان
همم بحمالات في سوشيال ميديا وليس لديهن
همم اختيار اخر الا ان يرفعنا همم صوتهن
عبر هذه الوسائل الاعلاميه شكرا لك من
كابول مراسل العربيه عبد الله نادر
الجماعه التي تدير الحكومه الان وتعتبر
نفسها بانها الحكومه تشكل الحكومه في
افغانستان لكن همم بوجود المؤسسات
الاجنبيه والاراثيه الاجنبيه في افغانستان
الحكومه غير قادره على تقديم هذه الخدمات
فبعد المغادره هذه المؤسسات من افغانستان
بكل تاكيد ستتفاقم الازمه بشكل كبير
وسيزيد الضغط على اعتق الحكومه التي هي
افضل عاجزه عن تقديم الخدمات للشعب
الخدمات في مختلفه في القطاعات التي
تغطيها هذه المنظمات الاغاثيه همم البديل
لابد على الحكومه ان تقدم بديلا وهي اصلا
عاجزه عن تقديم البديل لكن همم على اي حال
الضحيه همم ستكون شعبا الافغاني ال- الذي
يعيش اكثر من
79% من هذا الشعب تحت خط الفقر وهي شعب
وهو شعب محتاج جدا لهذه همم
المساعدات الانسانيه والاضافيه
الى ذلك ابدى الامين العام للامم المتحده
من الحضر الذي فرضته طالبان على عمل
النساء في المنظمات غير الحكوميه وقال
المتحدث باسم الامين العام ستيفاندو
جاغليك ان القراره سيقود عمل العديد من
المنظمات العامله لمساعده الفئات الاكثر
ضعفا وخاصه النساء والفتيات
وشدد على حق جميع نساء في المشاركه في
القوى العامله وخاصه في المجال الانساني
كما حذر جوترش من ان الحضره المفروض عليهن
سيؤدي الى مزيد من المشقه التي لا توصف
لشعبي افغانستان
من جانبها دعوات وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه
انا لينا باربوك الى ردم فعليه عالمي واضح
من المجتمع الدولي تجاه قرارات طالبان ضد
النساء وقالت باير بوك في تغريده ان
استبعاد نساء والفتيات من العمل والتعليم
والحياه العامه لا يدمر بلدهم فقط بل
يرتكبون جريمه ضد الانسانيه مضيفا ان
المانيا ستحاول الحصول على رد فعل واضح من
المجتمع الدولي
ونبقى في افغانستان فقط فقد كانت مروه على
بعد بضعه اشهر فقط من ان تصبح اول امراه
في عائلتها الافغانيه تلتحق بالجامعه
وبدلا من ذلك ستراقب بالم بينما يذهبوا
الشقيقها بدونها
داخل هذا المكان
كبرت احلام
وقبرت اخرى في بلاد تعاني فيها النساء من
نيل حتى ابسط حقوقهم
عندما سمعت عن هذا القرار كنت حزينه لا
استطيع ان اصف بالكلمات ما شعرت به في
اليوم الذي تلقيت فيه تلك الاخبار حتى لو
قرروا قطع رؤوس النساء لكان افضل من هذا
الحظر
خوف وياس ومستقبل مجهول
هكذا حياته خارج دائره الزمن بفعل قرار من
طالبه
اردت ان تحقق اختي اهدافها الى جانبي وان
تنجح وتمضي قدما رغم العديد من المشاكل
انا سعيده
لكن من ناحيه اخرى اشعر بالحزن
فسيكون لها مستقبل بائس مثلي
من الحياه العامه في افغانستان نهج تتبعه
طالبان دون اقتراس باضراره الكارثيه
الحاليه والمستقبليه في مواصله لاسلوبها
الدائم في تجهيل النساء
دقيقته في اضراب عن الطعام محمود مرض خالي
الشقيق فريده قال في تغريده على حسابه في
تويتر ان اخته فريده بدات اضرابا عن
الطعام احتجاجا على احتجازها وعدم نقلها
الى سجن ايفين ويذكر ان فريده مرض خان
اعتقالتها سلطات الايرانيه بعد تسجيلها
مقطع فيديو تصف فيه السلطات التي يقودها
خالها
بنظام المجرم وقاتل للاطفال
ومع مرور 100 يوم على الذراع الاحتجاجات
في ايران شهدت مدينه بركان في ايران
اضرابا عاما شمل جميع المتاجر لاحياء ذكرى
قتل الاحتجاجات
[موسيقى]
يواجه وحميد غازي حسن له وهو طبيب ايراني
حكما بالاعدام
مشاركته وزوجته التي حكمت بالسجن 25 عاما
في ضرب عضو في البرسيم ونقلت صحيفه واشنطن
بوس ان قوات الامن الايرانيه داهمت منزل
الطبيب وزوجته واعتقلتهما
وضربتهما امام ابنتهما البالغه من العمر
14 عاما
وكشف احد
اصدقائنا لصحيفه ان عناصر الامن الايراني
باسلحه مزومه في ولات عائله الطبيب انه
وزوجته لطالما قدما اعمالا انسانيه في
مسيرتهما منها محاوله مساعده رجل دين كان
يتعرض للضرب في الشارع
ويواجهما لا يقل عن 25 محتاجا ايرانيا
تهاما في وفاه عضو البسيج فيما حكم على
خمسه منهم بمن فيهم الطبيب بالاعدام وبشان
متصل نشر ممثل السينما والمسرح الايراني
اشكان خطيبي تفاصيل تجربته من العيش لمده
90 يوما في خوف وتخفن وقلق بعد تعرضه
لتهديدات النظام لتضامنه مع الاحتجاجات
واوضح الفنانه الايرانيه انه تعرض لهجوم
من قبل ضباط بزين مدني في الشارع بالاضافه
الى تهديده مرارا عبر هاتفه بالموت ما اذى
به الى المعاناه من نوبات عصبيه اصولا
لنجاته من جلطه قلبيه
ياتي هذا بينما يوصل النظام الايراني
ضغوطه على الممثلين السينمائيين واعتقاله
نحو 50 سينمائيا ايرانيا
لتضامنهم مع الاحتجاجات
وفي نشره الخامسه ولكن بعد الفاصل
رئيس الاركان الايراني يقر بالتعاون مع
دول لم يسمها لتطوير صناعه المسيرات
احييكم من جديد اقر رئيس الاركان الايراني
محمد باقري بان طهران تتعاونوا مع دول لم
يسمها لتطوير صناعه
تاتي تلك التصريحات وسطهامات غربيه لايران
بتزويد روسيا بطائرات مسيره تستخدمها في
عملياتها العسكريه على اوكرانيا
وافدت تحقيقنا اجره الجيش الاوكراني ومصدر
مطلع امريكي عن صنعتها شركه تكساس
انسرومنت للتكنولوجيا مقرها دالاس كانت من
بين المكونات التي تم العثور عليها في بعض
الطائره الايرانيه
الاركان قالت رئاسه الاوكرانيه ان روسيا
لا تريد مفاوضات وتتنصل من مسؤولياتها جاء
ذلك ردا على الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
الذي اكد ان بلاده مستعده للتفاوض بشان
حلول مقبوله مع جميع اطراف الصراع في
اوكرانيا لكنه اكد انهم رفضوا ذلك وقال
بوتين ان صراع في اوكرانيا قائم بسبب
اطماع خصومنا على حسب وصفه السياسيه
ورغبتهم في تفكيك روسيا واضاف ان موسكو
تحمي مصالحها الوطنيه ومواطنها من خلال
تحركاتها في اوكرانيا واشار الرئيس الروسي
الى ان العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا تسير
في الاتجاه الصحيح
اعلنت السلطات الاوكرانيه حاله التاهب
الجوي في العاصمه كيا اف وبقيه المقاطعات
في جميع انحاء البلاد تحسبا لغرات الروسيه
وذكرت تقارير اوكرانيه ان الانذار صدر بعد
رصد طائرات روسيه اقلعت من بيلاروسيا
وتزايد مخاطر وعقارات جويه
العربيه حذيفه عادل حذيفه ما الجديد
ميدانيا اولا
مساء الخير يعني عند ااا يعني دعيني ابدا
بهذا العاجل الذي قبل قليل اعلن عنه الجيش
الاوكراني اعلن عن هجوم مضاد في باخبط نتج
عنه استعاده بعض المواقع التي كان يسيطر
عليها الروس هذا طبعا يؤكد الفيديو الذي
انتشر على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي لاحد
الجنود الاوكرانيين الذين يعني الذي كان
وسط مدرعات واليات اوكرانيه وقال اننا في
منطقه اوبتنا وهي قريه متاخمه لباخ متانه
يسيطر عليها الروس لمده اما يزيد عن
الشهرين قال اننا دخلنا طبعا هو لم يكن
انا نستعد السيطره كامله هذه همم القريه
ولكن قال اننا دخلنا والان جاري عمليه همم
تمشيط في
وتقدم للقوات الاوكرانيه هذا طبعا همم
الان همم
يحدد المواقع التي سيطر عليها نتيجه هذا
الهجوم مضاد
استطاع من خلاله ان يسيطر على عده مواقع
همم بشكل عام اا المركز ابحاث الحرب
الاوكراني اليوم ايضا اعلن عن اا ان الجيش
الروسي همم ان هنالك يعني همم
ويخفف الجيش الروسي من هجومه في محور
باخته هنا نتحدث عن المحور الكبير
حتى سوليدار ولكن ايضا الجيش الاوكراني
وهيئه الاركان اعلنت عن ان هناك ثلاثه
محاور يركز الاتحاد الروسي الهجوم فيها
وهي باخم المدينه نفسها وايضا محور
الايمان ومحور افديرس كيف بالمقابل في
منطقه لوغاز الجيش الروسي يدافع اكثر
ويحاول الجيش الاوكراني التقدم والجيش
الروسي يعزز من دفاعاته الاستراتيجيه في
تلك المنطقه حيث تحاول القوات الاوكرانيه
الوصول الى صفاته الى كريمه حذيفه
عيد الميلاد في روسيا مخالفا لباقي الغرب
يعني ليس اليوم وانما في السته يناير
اعتقد
طبعا الاله الاوكرانيون يحتفلون باعياد
الميلاد في تاريخيين يعني للمواطنين الذين
يرغب في الاحتفال
صحيح هنالك مواطنين يرغبون في الاحتفال
على الطريقه على الطريقه الشرقي
واخرون يرغبون في الاحتفال بالتاريخ
الغربي لذلك الان اصبح ذلك عطلتين لاعياد
الميلاد
ويتم الاحتفال باي طريقه هنا في اوكرانيا
لسلطان طبعا التي تدخل في هذا الامر كما
افاده همم كما افادت السلطات همم لكن همم
عطله او هدنا طبعا الذي يتم الاعلان عن
ذلك ولكن اليوم كان هنالك تعليق لوزير
الدفاع الاوكرانيا قال ان الجيش الاوكراني
الجيش الروسي عفوا والروس حتى لا يفهمون
ولا يعرفون المناسبات الدينيه اولا يكون
هناك من قبله اي احترام لهذه المناسبات
الدينيه وسوف يواصلون عمليات القصف على
المدن الاوكرانيه في جميع المناطق عند
تعلمين ان كان هنالك هجوم اخير في مدينه
خيرسون ناتج عنه سته عشر قتيلا و68 جرحك
سؤال اخير ليست المره الاولى التي يقول
فيها انه يعرض التفاوض خارب لا يريد ما
ردود فعل هكذا تصريحات لبوتن داخل
اوكرانيا
طبعا الان ال- ال- السياسيين الاوكرانيين
اتحدث عن الاصل الاوكرانيه اتحدث عن
مستشار الرئيس همم بدلات وتحدث عن اندرير
ماكس دائما ما يعلقون على مثل هذه
التصريحات وكان هنالك تصريحات مشابهه
علقوا عليها وقالوا انهم لا يابهون ابدا
بتصريحات بوت هنالك بنود محدده للوصول الى
اتفاق اذا لم يكن هنالك الحد هذا الحد
الادنى من الاتفاق حول انسحاب الجيش
الروسي من كامل الاراضي الاوكرانيه ثم
طبعا عمليه همم ضمانات امنيه لاوكرانيا ثم
بعد ذلك اذا كان هنالك موافقه على ذلك
يمكن الجلوس
ولكن ايضا هم يقولون انهم فقدوا الثقه في
حكومه بوتين وهرانك مرسوم جمهوري وقع عليه
البرلمان واقره في عدم التفاوض مع الرئيس
بوتين نفسه فقط يعني يمكن التفاوض مع رئيس
اخر شكرا
واعلنت سلطات وزبوجيا المواليه لروسيا ان
شاء خطا دفاعيا عميق ومحصل
لافشاري اي تقدم من اوكراني وقالت في بيان
ان بناء الهياكل الدفاعيه على طول الخط
الامامي في ذا بوريجيا على شكل انتهاء هذا
وتواصل القوات الاوكرانيه قصف مواقع
وتمركزت القوات روسيه
قصف مواقع وتمركزات القوات الروسيه
بالمدفعيه ويتبادل الطرفين الاتهامات
بتهديد سلامه المنشئه نوويه هناك
من بوسكو معي مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد
الرشد اهلا بك ايضا ما المستجدات ميداليه
بشكل اولي تحديدا زبوريجيا
مرحبا
دفاعي تحضيرا لاي هجمات اوكرانيا وصد كافه
الهجمات المضاده في تلك المناطق الجميع
يعرف المنطقه واوضاعه هناك والفتره التي
تعيشها خلال الاشهر الست الماضيه وما
يصاحبها من سقوط لقذائف وصواريخ خاصه على
محطه زبارو جانويه وهي الاكبر في القاره
العجوز نقطه تهديد واضحه طبعا وزباروجيا
تعتبر خط التماس الاول وخط المواجهه بين
قوات موسكو والقوات الاوكرانيه ما يفصل
للجانبنا الان فقط هو همم يعني خط النهر
نهر النيبر موسكو كانت قدي يعني قصفت
ودمرت جميع الجسور التي تصل بين الطرفين
لذلك نلاحظ بان العمليات العسكريه من
الجهه العليا حسب حسب رؤيه المحللين
السياسيين والعسكريين تقتصر على الضربات
الصاروخ والتحرك قليلا عبر مياه نهر
النيبر هذا بما يخص طبعا المنطقه الشماليه
خرسه طبعا ما زال تحت وط-ت سقوط القذائف
وكيف وموسكو تقوم طبعا بالقاء الاتهام همم
يعني على الاخر بينهما ايضا دانيتكم ما
زالت تعيش اصعب الاوقات الجانب الروسيه
تحدث عن سقوط اكثر من 10 همم قذائف خلال
الساعات الاربعه والعشرين الماضيه البعض
منها قال ما بان سكنيه والبعض الاخر قال
المرافق الحيويه والسوق في وسط المدينه
هذا بما يخص الاشياء الميداني
عبد الجواد ان يكون هناك هدنه عيد الميلاد
بحسب تقويم الكنيسه الشرقيه من قبل روسيا
ريما يعني حتى هذه اللحظه لم يعلن عن هذا
الشيء ابدا لا موسكو ولا كيف قامت بالحديث
عن هذا الشيء في يعني في الاوراق الروسيه
لا شيء يذكر حول هذا الموضوع لكن طبعا اذا
تم قراءه ما بين السطور حديث الرئيس غادي
مربوطن اليوم بما يخص المفاوضات بين موسكو
والغرب فانه طبعا تحدث عن ثلاثه ملفات
رئيسيه الملف الاول طبعا هو انا موسكو
جاهزا للمفاوضات على عكس الشركاء الغربيين
كما سماهم ايضا طبعا تحدث عن ان موسكو
ستقوم باستهداف كافه منظمات الدفاع الجوي
التي قد تزود بها واشنطن كيف وطبعا الملف
اهم من هذا كله بوت تحدث عن ان سير
العمليه العسكريه هو مستمر وموسكو يعني
مستمره في طريقها ويعني ترى به الصواب في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وهذا لخدمه حمايه
مواطنها ولمصالحها
عبد الجواب عبد الجواد كرر اكثر من مره
موضوع التفاوض بوتين وبانه الغرب يرفض
لماذا هذا التكرار
يعني بوتن يبحث عن التفاوض في هذا الموضوع
عمليته العسكريه دخلت الارضيه الاوكرانيه
لحمايه مناطق الدمباس والمناطق المجاوره
لها لكن طبعا في الوضع على الارض الان
يعني الجانب الروسي والكثير من القراءات
السياسيه في البلاد ترى بان المفاوضات
اليوم هي الحل الاوفر والافضل لكافه
الاطراف لكن طبعا موسكو تعود وتكرر بان
ليس لدى الغرب اي يعني همم خطوه ايجابيه
بهذا الموضوع وبالمناسبه وصفات ما يقوم به
الغرب بالخطوه الاستفزازيه حسب رؤيه موسكو
لهذا يعني
شكرا لك من موسكو مراسل العربيه
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
انهد شهرها العاشر العاشر هذه الحرب
القائمه تسببت بنزوح الالف من الروس خارج
البلاد حتى وان بعضهم وصل للولايات
المتحده طالبين
روسي يعمل حاليا على تشريع يفرض ضرائب
اعلى للذين غادروا البلاد والغاء امتيازات
يحظى بها
المواطنون الروس
موجه فراري جماعي للروس في الشهور الماضيه
بسبب العمليه العسكريه الروسيه وخصوصا مع
قرار بوت للتعبئه وضريبه ذلك فرد ضرائب
اعلى رئيس مجلس النواب الروسي فيتش سلفا
لودن قال ان المجلس يعمل على تشريع ينص
بزياده الضرائب على من غادر البلاد والغاء
امتيازات يحظى بها المواطنون واصفا من ترك
روسيا بالخائنين لوطنهم وفقا ما صرح به
المسؤول الروسي على تيليجرام
هذا وقد افادت وكاله رويترز نقلا عن وسائل
اعلام روسيه في اوائل اكتوبر بفراري ما
يصل الى 700000 بعد اعلان بوتن التعبئه
الجزئيه لقوات الاحتياط في الجيش سبتمبر
الماضي لاستدعاء ما يصل الى 300,000
للقتال يذكر ان نسبه ضريبه الدخل في روسيا
تبلغ 13% وتخصم تلقائيا من الموظفين
المحليين وبحسب هيئه الضرائب الاتحاديه
الروسيه يجب على الروس العاملين بالخارج
ولديهم التزامات ضريبيه دفعها بشكل مستقل
رشا خياطه العربيه
نشرت صحيفه نيويورك تايم تقريرا يفيد بان
الولايات المتحده ستقدم اسلحه تسمح لاقراء
لاوكرانيا بتوجيه ضربات دقيقه التوجيه ضمن
حزمه المساعدات العسكريه الجديده وقيمتها
مليار و850 مليون دولار واوضحت صحيفه ان
واشنطن ستسلم اوكرانيا سلاح جي دعم المسمى
بذخيره الهجوم المباشر المشترك لضمان دقه
التوجيه وهو سلاح لم تكن تمتلكه من قبل
هذا وسيمكن السلاح من تحويل القنابل غير
الموجهه الى سلاح عالي الدقه بنظام تحديد
المواقع العالمي جي بي اس وسيتم استخدام
السلاح الامريكي الجديد قريبا من قبل
طيارين الاوكرانيين لمواجهه الغزو الروسي
وفقا لتقرير نيويورك تايمز
قال وزير الخارجيه الصينيه
العلاقات بين الصين وروسيا قائمه على
التعاون ودعم المصالح الجوهريه للبلدين
مشيرا الى بلدين
قاما بخطوات مهمه لتعزيز التعاون في كل
المجالات
حسن الجوار والصداقه والتعاون مع روسيا
وجعلت شراكه التنسيق الاستراتيجيه الشامله
بين الصين
ومرونه في العام الماضي كما ان الصين
وروسيا دعمتها بعضهم البعض بقوه في
المصالح الجوهريه
السياسيه والاستراتيجيه المتبادله كما ان
تجاره الثنائيه تقارب المئتين مليار دولار
في وتيره اسرع وهناك مشاريع استثماريه
كبيره
نحن نحب الجانب الامريكي على الوفاء
بالتزاماته
الايجابيه الى افعل ووقف التدخل في الشؤون
الداخليه للصين في تقويض سياده الصين
وامنها ومصالحها التنمويه وذلك لتهيئه
مناخ ملائم للتواصل والتعاون بين الجانبين
كما ندعوا الجانب الامريكي الى تغيير
مساره وارساء تصور موضوعا ومعقول للصين
واتباع سياسه ايجابيه وعمليه تجاه بلادنا
والعمل معنا لوضع الركائز والاساس المتين
للعلاقه بين البلدين
الى ذلك اعلن الجيش الصيني اجراءا مناورات
بحريه وجويه حول جزيره تايوان وذكر بيان
للجيش الصيني ان هذه المناورات تاتي ردا
على مواصفه بالتصعيد الامريكي التايواني
وتعهد باتخاد كل الاجراءات اللازمه لحفظ
سياده الصين وسلامتها الاقليميه
وفي نشات الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
يعلن مليون اصابه كرونا يوميا في مدينه
تشنج ويقول ان العدد سيتضاعف خلال ايام
احييكم من جديد و نتابع من ليبيا اعلن
مدير اداره التوجيه المعنوي بالقياده
العامه للجيش اللي بي خالد المحجوب ان
قياده الجيش تنتظر موقف القوى الوطنيه
والسياسيه لتوافق على خريطه
المهمه لم يكشف عنها كما نفى المسؤول
الليبي وجودانيه لدى الجيش باعلان انفصال
اقليمي
برقه وفزان عن طرابلس متهما من وصفهم
بمردده الاكاذيب بمحاوله محاوله التشكيك
في قياده الجيش وفقا تعبيره
معي خالد محجوب اللواء ومدير اداره
التوجيه المعنوي في القوات المسلحه
العربيه الليبيه حدث اللواء اهلا بك ماذا
تعني عندما تقول هناك سيناريوهات سيئه
ويعني وجهت انذار
انذار حقيقي اذا ما كانت هذه يعني حول هذه
السيناريوهات
القائد العام المشير خليفه
مساء امس او ظهيره الامس في الكلمه كانت
واضحه الرساله وقويه همم ان ما يحدث الان
لا يمكن السكوت عنه هناك تواصل مع كل
المناطق في ليبيا تعلن عن رفضها واسياها
باستمرار هذا الوضع وايضا استعدادها
للتعاون
والتعامل مع الموقف همم بما يقتضيه همم في
ظل همم ما تحدث عنه همم القائد العام بان
القوات المسلحه دائما للشعب وداعمه للحراك
الوطنيه
التي الان بدات بالفعل طلاب لما همم يعني
همم جموحها وتسعه لان تنطلق في عام
الوطنيه بكل تاكيد هام جدا في هذه المرحله
الليبيينهم همم مساله تدوير الازمه والح
وماتت التي تاتي همم كجرعات علاج مؤقت في
الحقيقه كانت تزيد الازمات سوءا عليه سواء
في معيشته ووصلت حتى الى انتهاء سيادته
وهو ما اصبح يعبر عنه المواطن
الا ماذا ما هي الخيارات امام الجيش
بكل تاكيد هناك التواصل قلت لك مع القوه
الوطنيه وكل المناطق بتاثيراتها
الاجتماعيه والقبائليه وايضا تاثيراتها
همم حتى الاداريه فيما لو استمر الوضع كما
هو عليه خصوصا بعد مجموعه من التصرفات
التي همم يعني يتبعها المواطن همم من
الحكومه التي الان همم تتواجد في طرابلس
ويعتبر الان طلب بعض المناطق ايضا حتى
محتله
والفقي حتى ل همم ليس فقط لا الشرعيه ولكن
فقط للسيادتها بمطلق الكلمه
التي يطلب منها القوات المسلحه باعتبارها
اكثر من ثلاثه ارباع البلد بالتاكيد همم
طول السكوت وايضا المناطق التي ترزختها
العسكريه الخيارات حضره اللواء امامكم
كاريه امسيه شو يعني لن يطول السكوت ماذا
ستفعلون
نحن نحن الان مع هذا الانذار وهذا الخيار
وعندما تتبدل الاحوال لدينا اوراقا التي
سنكشف عنها ان شاء الله عندما تتحدث عن
سيناريوات سيئه ماذا اسوء بالنسبه لليبيا
من الوضع الحالي
يعني الدوله بهذا الشكل اذا باستمر كما هو
على ايه سنفقد حتى يعني ستصبح الدوله
مدانه صندوق النقد ستفقد قدراتها على يعني
سترت اصبح دوله فاشله للاسف يعني بهذه
الاداره بهذا الشكل الذي يستمر فيه نزف
ثروات البلد يستمر فيه فقدان سيادتها
يستمر فيه انتهاء المواطن كل ما يحصل الان
وجود القوات الاجنبيه وغيرها كل هذه
الامور الحقيقه همم المواطن لم يعد يرى
بامكان ان يستمر السكوت عليها وبالتالي
همم اذا ما وصل الحال الى قوه المواطن
بهذا الشكل والتفكر ليبيا حتى قدرتها
الماليه رغم انها الدوله الدوله التلوات
هل هل التقطيع او التقد رائحه الخيارات
السيئه
سيناريوهات سيئه
لا هناك فرق بين دوله فاشله وبين التقسيم
نحن كثوره الكرامه ثوره واحده وايه ليس
لها علاقه بهذه همم
الترهات التي يدعيها البعض نحن ابدا لن
نكون قاسم في اي تقسيم في ليبيا بالعكس
نحن من حافظ على همم يعني الكيان الليبي
نحن من نسى الى ان لم ليبيا نحن من نسى
الى ان تكون ليبيا واحده لا يمكن ان تقبل
القسمه ابدا وبالتالي همم هذا همم شيء لا
يمكن التفكير فيه هناك دعايه ظهرت حاول
البعض تشويه بها القياده العامه وان هناك
رغبه في ذلك من اجل السلطه وهذا غير حقيقي
يعني تم رد ذلك عليهم بقوه بالامس عندما
تم تفنيد كل هذه الشائعات الكبيره
المعنوي في القوات المسلحه العربيه اللي
فيها شكرا لك
الى السودان اودت اشتباكات القبليه في
ولايه جنوب دارفور بحياه 11 شخصا على
الاقل في المنطقه التاسعه المطربه الواقعه
غرب السودان وفقه ما اصاب افاد مصدر الطبي
حيث
منذ ايام بين قبائل العربيه من الرعاه
واخرى افريقيه في قريه قريبه من نيالا
عاصمه ولايه جنوب دارفور وفق ما افاد شهود
عيان
ارتفع عدد قتلافجار صهريج وقود قرب
جوهانسبورغ في جنوب افريقيا الى 15 شخصا
وكان الصهريج ينقل 60 الف لتر من الغاز
المسال وايضا في جاره الى سقوط عشرات
القتلى والجرحى
الى فرنسا اعلنت المدعيه العملي باريس ان
المتقاعد الذي اعترف بقتل ثلاثه اكراد في
باريس قال انه ذهب اولا الى بلده في ضاحيه
ساندوني الشماليه للعاصمه باريس لارتكاب
جرائم قتل ضد الاجانب وذكرت المدعيه
العامه الفرنسيه انه تخلى عن التوجه الى
ضواحي باريس لقله الموجودين وصعوبه اعاده
ملئ السلاحا وانه فضل تنفيذ الهجوم في
منطقه مقتضى واضافت ان الرجل البالغ من
العمر 69 عاما اعترف بانه يكون كراهيه
للاجانب حتى اصبحت حاله مرضيه تماما
من بليز معي مراسل العربيه حسين قنيبر
حسين اهلا بك يعطيك الف عافيه على
هاليومين اللي كان مفترض انها تكون هادئه
بعيد الميلاد هناك تفاصيل عن التحقيقات
مثيره ما هي
ريما شكرا لك
تفاصيل بعضها ذكرته في مقدمه الخبر والبعض
الاخر يتمثل في قول المعتدي طبعا انا
هناجئت الى المنطقه التي شهدت مواجهات
عنيفه بين الغاضبين الاكراد وعناصر الشرطه
امس سيارات مقلوبه واخرى محترقه وايضا
وجهات تو محل تجاريه وجهاد زجاجيه تضررت
جرح 31 شرطيا ومتظاهر واحد واوقف احد 10
مثيرا للشغب كما قال الشرطه اعود الى
المعلومات التي نشرتها النيابه العامه في
باريس بالاضافه الى ما ذكرتي المعتدي قال
انه كان يرغب في تفريق كل الرصاصات التي
كانت في حوزته ضد اجانب ضد مهاجرين مهما
كانت جنسيتهم كما انه كان يريد
الانتحار كان يريد ان الرصاصه الاخيره
التي كانت بحوزته على نفسه وقال انه منذ
ان تعرض منزله للسرقه عام 2016 اصبح يتم
حقدا مرضيا على المهاجرين اصبح راغبا في
الانتحار وفي قتل مهاجرين نقل بعض ظهر امس
المعتدي الى مصحه نفسيه تابعه لشرطه باريس
لان وضعه الصحي كما قال الطبيب الذي عينه
لم يعد يسمح بالابقاء عليه اضمن الحبس
الاحتياطي ومدته ست وتسعون ساعه لكن
المعتدي لا يمكن ان يبقى سته و90 ساعه دون
الحبس الاحتياطي نظرا لظروفها الصحيه يعني
لا اصدق
او بمعركه حسين العلاقه بين الاكراد
وسلطات الفرنسيه جيده لماذا لم يمن
القيمون على الاكراد على المتظاهرين في
الشارع ومحدثي الشغب
سؤالك سؤال كيما طرح بطريقه ما امس على
احد المسؤولين الاكراد في باريس فاقر بان
الوضع تجاوزنا كل تصريحات المسؤولين
الاكراد كما قال المتحدث باسم المجلس
الديمقراطي لكردستان في باريس كل تصريحات
المسؤولين الاكراد ذهبت في اتجاه التهدئه
وضبط الامور لكن كان هناك غضب كبير خصوصا
ان اشخاصا كانوا علامات شاحنه صغيره قالوا
كلاما
وارسل اشارات مستفزه فكان الرد عليهم كما
قال هذا المسؤول الكردي بالفعل العلاقات
جيده جدا بين الاكراد بين فصائلهم
واحزابهم وجاليتهم هنا وبين السلطات
الفرنسيه اليوم الاول بعد قتل الثلاثي
الذي حصل الجمعه كان هادئ النسبيا راينا
مجموعات من الاكراد تحاول تهدائه الغاضبين
من الاكراد وتفصل بينهم وبين القوى
الامنيه لكن الامور امس تطورت بعد هذا
الاستفزاز الذي قام به من كانوا على شاحنه
صغيره الاشاره اخيره لو سمحتي لي الى ان
تصريحات المسؤولين الفرنسيين التي تلاحقت
امس المسؤولون الفرنسيون اكدوا دعمهم
للجاليه الكرديه وقالوا ان موقفنا الداعم
للاكراد ثابت لا يتزعزع كما قال حرفيا
وزير العدل الفرنسيه
والامور تبدو طبيعيه اليوم في باريس
تواجه المقاطعه الصناعيه في الصين اصابات
مرتفعه بفايروس كورونا وصلت الى المليون
يوميا ومن المتوقع ان تتضاعف وفق حكومه
المقاطعه ومع هذا الارتفاع بالاصابات ذكرت
الصين انه لا توجد وفيات في البر الرئيسيه
للايام الخمسه الماضيه واصبحت الارقام على
صعيد الصين غير مكتمله بعد ما توقفت لجنه
الصحه الوطنيه عن الابلاغ عن اعداد
الاصابات بما يجعل من الصعب تتبع الحالات
بالعوده الى الملف الاوكرانيه
بحفله عيد الميلاد من قبل تحت الارض تحسبا
من القصب وتجنبا لازعاجي صفارات الانذار
التي تذوي بشكل شبه يومي في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه منذ 10 اشهر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وهذه واقفه مع ابرز الصور
هذا العام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
شكرا وانا نلتقي في نشره المساء شكرا
دائما للمتابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]